[Musique]
françaises français
mes chers compatriotes de l'hexagone et
de l'outre-mer j'ai l'honneur de
m'adresser à vous ce soir le plus
sobrement possible afin de vous
souhaiter tous mes voeux pour cette
nouvelle année
j'en profite également pour vous
annoncer que tpm paix devient une
émission plus sérieuse que culturel qui
sera au coeur de l'actualité et je ferai
tout pour mener cette réforme à bien
pour ma part comme vous pouvez le voir
la rigueur sera mon fer de lance
afin d'élever le débat vous l'avez
compris
chers compatriotes 2020 sera pour moi
l'année de la maturité de la sagesse et
surtout du bon avec pour preuve mon
envie de me réconcilier avec cette
chaîne qui commence par un thé et qui
finit par un regardez donc juste après
le générique ce qui suit qui va dans le
bon sens le sens de l'apaisement
merci à tous
[Musique]